foreign
Detroit hey Max what's up
I deserve how can I help
okay
my dad and my mother I had last year my
dad caught
um he got sicko he had got lung cancer
so I live in Michigan so I had been
traveling back and forth taking care of
my mom and my dad through the chemo and
just passed of last January he just
passed away
um she didn't really oh thank you she
did really good in the stock market but
when he got sick we didn't realize till
after the death that so much money had
been lost through the Investments okay
so I put her back with my aunties and
then back in Chicago that's where
originally were from Once has you know
kind of passed you know the healing time
a little bit it's kind of easy but she's
been really on me about moving her back
to Florida and just quitting my job and
just taking care of her
okay so you talked about a series of
Investments so is there a lot of money
that your parents had
well you know what we when we started
when my dad was talking to me we was
about 7 25 but now we're down to 400.
wow they do have a
because no one took care of the stock
market when he got sick the stock market
hasn't gone in half
well whatever Investments he had it went
down no one took care of it he was the
owner who's taking care of it now
my cousin's been took place of it
because he's the only one that really
kind of was investing in the family
why is your cousin taking care of your
and your mother's money
yeah Max this is going to be gone
overnight in a vapor
I don't know because he was the one who
just my mom was like well Nick knows how
to do the stuff in investing and kind of
how old is your mother
uh 86. yeah
okay
we still have the house in Florida it's
fully paid for but the thing was I mean
you live in Detroit what do you do for a
living yes
well I worked at the casino okay
do you want to live in Florida
no I want to actually go to Texas where
my children I have all grown children
and grandbabies and my ultimate goal was
getting back to Texas and then this had
happened to my dad and now my mom is by
herself I'm an only child so here's what
your mom used to do she needs to call
Nick
and get her money
and she needs to sit down with you and a
good investment broker and put her money
to work the money that the 400 000 will
earn for an 86 year old can hire her
someone to help her to help take care of
her
right that's what we that's what she
wanted to do she's like that's what she
needs to do and that's not you
that's no then that's what I feel
sometimes but then the whole family is
like the only person I don't care what
the whole family facts doesn't want to
go they don't get a vote Max now if your
mom wants to move with you to Texas then
you can lay that out and say I'm happy
to have you come move in with me in
Texas and we'll hire some skilled
nursing or whatever we needed at the
house I don't know what taking care of
her means
but Max this all these people telling
you what to do living their life getting
to use you like like a Nintendo joystick
they don't get to do that it's not their
life they don't get a vote
I feel bad
why
what you doing
wrong what'd you do wrong but if you
invite your mom to Michigan you've been
taking care of your mom you've been
taking care of your dad your appearanced
dreams they didn't want to just right
they didn't want to go to Michigan when
I said let's go to Michigan but that's
where their dog lives their choice if
they want me to take care of them they
have to come where I am yeah she's a
grown-up
she gets to make adult decisions she
does not get to dictate to you anymore
with her mother voice you are like a
grown person and she's an 86 year old
old woman
right and she is trust me Dave and I
talk to enough people she is beyond the
Moon that she has raised a daughter with
Integrity who cares about her family and
loves her mom enough to have walked
alongside her as she lost her husband
and you lost your dad that's amazing
yeah
but so I want to give you a line okay
your mother your mother tells you what
to do by throwing out guilt trips she's
a travel agent for guilt trips isn't she
yes it works all right I want you to do
this why I'm taking the plane with it
when she drops it on me I take the plane
with it and I'm like oh why don't you
why don't you just why don't you say
it's not gonna work anymore
I have to get over that part all right
Max I'm gonna give you a line and I want
you to tattoo it on your heart okay
okay this is not my line it I don't
remember who came up with it but here's
what it is
I want you to choose guilt over
resentment every time
because if you don't choose guilt
over resentment
you are going to end up hating your mom
that she took away moments with your
grandbabies from you and that's not fair
to her that's not fair to you
that's right and so I'd rather feel
guilty that hey I want to be with my
kids and my grandbabies and I want their
great grandma with them but she's a
grown woman if she chooses Florida over
all that then she chooses to Florida
over all that
yeah she gets to choose
okay as long as long as she's of her
right mind otherwise the court will
choose for her
oh I think she's of her right mind she's
used to getting her way
she's been bossing people around for
about 86 years and getting away with it
and she's probably also
um wading through that grief and she's
put a leash on you and said you drag me
through this grief in whichever way I
want to go that's not how that works how
that works yeah so Mom I love you
and I'll be happy to help you we're
going to get your money if I'm going to
help you here's the terms you're going
to live in Texas where I'm moving to to
be near the grandbabies and you'll see
your great-grandbabies and we're going
to get your money from Nick and we're
going to put it with a professional
money manager that will help us and
teach us how to create an income so we
can hire some help to take care of you
while I'm at work but you can live in my
home and I will love you and take care
of you I am not coming to Florida if you
don't want to do that those two things
it's okay Mom you're it's your choice
the law says that you are allowed to
make your own decisions and it says I am
too and so I'm going to Texas love to
have you otherwise I'll come see you in
Florida uh when I got some days off
and if you want me to help you set up
some care over there I will but I love
you but I'm sorry I get to choose and I
want if let's say she does choose
Florida
I want your heartbreak to not be that
um
you finally decided that your life had
value too I want your heartbreak to be
my mom chose
a retirement village in another state
over me and her grandkids and her great
grandkids that's heartbreaking oh break
my heart
that's a total of like 180 to it's your
job to
completely cancel out your life and live
wherever she tells you to live and do
whatever she tells you to do
um it flip that thing around man flip
that thing around yeah
she does not
have a vote unless you give her one so
take her vote from her
on where Max lives
don't get a vote anymore mom and you'll
have to say it out loud but you just say
it in your mind just smile and go
you know you don't you don't get to
decide that now and Dave uh just the
added complexity
sometimes that parent says well then you
may just not have access to this money
then whatever and you have to decide is
your soul for sale right yeah yeah
that's that's perfectly okay because
apparently I didn't have access to start
with it Nick has it and Nick's got it
the cousin Nick the cousin
don't let your cousin sell your house or
manage your money
those are Rand those are new Ramsay
rules I just made up you just made them
up on the spot deloney Rams are deloni
rams
[Music]